One of the best known tools for
batch processing raster and
vector images is ImageMagick.
ImageMagick is a free and open source
tool that enables you to automate
just about anything you might normally
do with a GUI based image editor.
Such as converting formats or
cropping or applying filters.
Now for responsive images, this means
you can automate the process of
creating multiple versions of the same
image with different sizes or formats.
In this example I'm using the
ImageMagick convert command to create
a webp goanna.
Let's open those in Chrome.
Identical.
Cool thing is, the webp goanna is
about 10% smaller than the jpg.
That could make quite a difference
on a flaky connection.
In this example, I've written a shell
script that uses ImageMagick to
create small and large versions of
my original photographic images,
saving in webp and JPEG formats.
Note that massive
reduction in file sizes.
There's my originally goanna.
And these are the versions
that I created.
You can incorporate ImageMagick in
your build process via a Grunt task.
In this example,
I'm using Grunt responsive images
to automate production of images,
just like I did with the shell script.
And then you can see the output.
I've got a bunch of images
saved at 50% width and
30% width in JPEG format
at different quality sizes.
There are a couple of really useful
apps that combine other tools for
image optimization.
For example, ImageOptim enables
lossless image optimization using
a number of open source tools.
Pngout, pngcrush,
jpegoptim Giftical and so on.
Now look at the file sizes of
our images before and after.
ImageAlpha uses pngquant and
other tools for compression.
ImageAlpha can reduce 24-bit PNG files
by applying lossy compression and
converting to PNG-8 plus alpha format.
Look at our PNG sizes before and after.
But looking at that, it went down from
about 330 kilobytes to around about 118.
That's like, around half the size.
As well as the GUI
versions you've just seen,
tools like ImageOptim and ImageAlpha
can also be run from the command line.
And incorporated with
your build process.
In this example I'm running
ImageOptum as a Grunt task.
That means you can incorporate automated
image optimization in your work flow.
To learn more about Grunt,
along with Imageoptum and
other command line tools,
follow the links below the video.